Is it okay to use right frequency for parasites and can need a daily or two to three times
a week? Sure. You can do it every single day. If you don't have parasites and you're
running parasite, it's not going to do anything. But if you have parasites, you're going to
kill parasites. Now, the parasite frequencies and the Candida frequencies, you know, could
you kill too fast and cause issues? Not really. Where you could kill too fast and cause
issues using the right machine is if you're killing a gram negative bacteria. So, what
will gram negative bacteria be? Well, mainly the most common is Lyme disease, Borrelia
Mercedorphi, the gram negative bacteria for Lyme disease. And why is that bad? Is gram
negative bacteria have lipopolysaccharides in the cell and their cell wall? And would
you kill a gram negative bacteria? You liberate lipopolysaccharides and lipopolysaccharides
stimulate an immune function, it abudes a stimulation. And if you already have a photo immune
issues, which many Lyme patients have, they get what's called a Herkseimer reaction and
they get you're really sick. So, that's the only negatives about using the right zip you
have Lyme, you don't want to try to kill too quickly. There isn't, you know, if you're
ready, you know, any other frequencies like that are non- Lyme programs, you're going to
be just fine.